I've been talking to you for years about
this really sickening alliance that
exists between the United States and
Saudi Arabia and we've talked about how
Saudi Arabia uh in spite of that sharing
many of the same extremist religious
views as many of our enemies in the
Middle East are one of our greatest
allies and about two weeks ago the Saudi
defense minister Prince Mohammed bin
Salman announced that Saudi Arabia would
lead a coalition of Muslim nations
around the world in order to help fight
terrorism visa V the Islamic state great
news right i mean fantastic except for
the fact that many of the views of the
islamic state are shared by saudi
arabia's extremist form of islam
Wahhabism but at least saudi arabia
wants stable extremist regimes rather
than belligerent extremists terrorists
or something I guess Louis maybe it's
marginally better well if if whatever a
nation ends up the you know if Iraq or
Syria end up being basically like Saudi
Arabia yeah which I guess it kinda
basically were like before maybe not as
religious uh that's better than what it
would be right now right I don't think
we could argue with that however here's
the other side of the equation on the
one side we have Saudi Arabia saying
they are fighting terror but is Ring of
Fire rights Saudi royals have been
financing terrorist organizations for
over 40 years and Republican
presidential candidates are not talking
about it remember that most of the nine
eleven hijackers were Saudis but also uh
Hillary Clinton is not talking about it
we don't hear Bernie Sanders talking
about it too much although he's talked
about it a little bit and remember
according to intelligence reports there
is a high likelihood that the hijackers
of 9-11 were aided and abetted by
officials of the Saudi government we've
heard from former Senator Bob Graham of
Florida that he claims the FBI is
withholding information about this
Republican candidates aren't talking
about it Secretary of State Clinton in
2009 publicly identified Saudi Arabia as
quote the most significant source of
funding to suny terrorist groups
worldwide has anybody heard Hillary
Clinton talking about the Saudis now
that she's running for president you'd
think this would be a terrific
opportunity for her to call out the
Republican candidates for not talking
about it but no because she essentially
seems as complicit in the whole thing as
everybody else and on salon.com David
Massie ohta mass ryota Massie otra I
think is the correct pronunciation of
his name wrote that the alliance between
Saudi Arabia and the u.s. is quote
mostly a one-way relationship in which
the u.s. is subservient and obsequious
essentially a harem to the Saudi royal
family who connect collect all the
benefits and rewards why are they
talking about this maybe the oil is just
that important or maybe they think it is
really important to have a what I guess
you could call in a lie in Saudi Arabia
uh I don't know I mean they can cake
take care of themselves maybe we just
need the oil maybe so and maybe it's the
interest in in sort of a certain type of
stability in the Middle East that Saudi
Arabia shares an interest in the past
year don't forget that it has been a
banner year for Saudi Arabia in terms of
human rights violations the Saudi
government has publicly beheaded more
so-called criminals uh over the last
year than at any time over the past two
decades includes offenses such as
abandoning faith leaving Islam or
practicing witchcraft I mean literally
am a an imaginary fantasy world
so-called crime the government routinely
tortures and murders its own citizens as
well as foreigners yet we continue the
relationship and we don't have any
serious critique of that alliance coming
from our Republican and Democratic
candidates the Saudi Arabia thing is
perverse and there is no sign at all
that it is going to change anytime soon
no I don't imagine so uh you know it's I
i think it's an allegiance that the
military industrial complex wants to
keep uh that the generals want to keep
and that the administration has always
wanted to keep so yeah where's it gonna
go